الضرر الهائل الذي خلفه زلزال تركيا يعود
لقدرته تدميريه الضخمه والمساحه التي
انتشر عليها والتي تشهد كثافه سكانيه
كبيره تابعوا مزيدا من التفاصيل
عن ليس سهلا تصور الضرر الهائل الذي احدثه
الزلزال فقد بلغت القدره التدميريه
للزلزالين ثلاثين كواد
بما يعادل نحو قنبله نوويه كتلك التي ضربت
هيروشيما من حيث القوه فحسب اذ ان الزلازل
لا تصدر اشعاعات نوويه جزء من الاضرار
الكبيره للزلزال هو المساحه الهائله التي
ضربها في عشر ولايات تركيه وتقدر باكثر من
100 الف كيلو متر مربع بما يزيد عن مساحه
دوله كالنمسا
الكثافه السكانيه في هذه المنطقه عاليه
جدا ايضا فعدد السكان في تلك الولايات
العشر يزيد عن 13 مليون ونصف مليون نسمه
فضلا عن اثر الزلزال على دول اخرى كسوريا
ولبنان والاردن وفلسطين وقد بلغ عمق
الزلزال في تركيا سبعه كيلومترات تحت
الارض
الى تزحزح الارض ثلاثه امتار تقريبا كما
بلغ طول الفالق 500 كيلومتر الرقم كبير
اذا ما قرن بزلزال السيشوان في الصين
والذي بلغ 300 كيلومتر او كاليفورنيا عام
1906 الذي بلغ نحو 400 كيلومتر